flammeninferno auf lesbos tausende von
migranten obdachlos brandursache unklar
die griechischen behörden vermuten
brandstiftung das flüchtlingslager ist
für 2800 menschen ausgelegt es leben
dort aber über 12.000 migranten die
katastrophalen zustände sind seit jahren
bekannt doch die griechischen behörden
bekommen die situation nicht in den
griff trotz hilfsgeldern von der eu soll
deutschland im alleingang helfen
nrw-ministerpräsident laschet wir bis zu
1000 flüchtlinge aufnehmen
bundesinnenminister seehofer sagt nein
nur wenn es eine europäische lösung gibt
doch andere länder sperren sich der
streit um europas migrationspolitik geht
weiter da sind ganz ganz schreckliche
bilder die wir da jetzt seit vielen
stunden wahrnehmen müssen und ich glaube
das war schon im großen ganzen sagen
kann wenn man solche bilder sieht das
ist ein nicht kalt lässt und dass man
natürlich instinktiv sagt da muss man
helfen ja da glaube ich sind wir uns
hier mit sehr vielen menschen auch da
draußen einig aber die frage ist wie
hilft man jetzt effektiv wie hilft man
jetzt gut und da gehen unter anderem
auch unsere meinung doch mal wieder
etwas auseinander
es wurde gerade schon angesprochen dass
es eine eu problem ist so muss ich
ehrlich sagen sehe ich das auch und ich
finde dass das jetzt auf großer ebene
geklärt werden muss und und ganz
besonders enttäuscht mich immer wieder
das ganz bestimmte länder sich dagegen
entscheidend zu helfen also dass man
sofort hilfe schaltet auch immer als
deutschland finde ich super und das muss
auch sein
aber da muss man natürlich ins gericht
mit dem ganzen gene warum ist das
passiert wie konnte es so weit kommen
und so sehr ich meine heimat norwegen
auch lieber aber wenn ich dann
wiederholt mitbekommen dass sie sich
weigern leute aufzunehmen leuten zu
helfen wo es wirklich im wahrsten sinne
des wortes brands da wird mir übel von
also das kann einfach nicht sein diese
verteilung muss aufgelöst werden finde
ich und gerade norwegen das führt
reichste land der welt
wir haben super voraussetzungen sie
haben viel platz da finde ich schon dass
wir wirklich ab großer ebene reden
müssen auf großer ebene reden vor allem
deshalb weil die leidtragenden die
menschen sind die wir dort sehen also
die letztlich auch zerrieben werden mit
einem teil der demokratie denn nicht
zuträglich ist die zum spielball gemacht
worden sind
und ich glaube auch dass wir uns mit
unseren werten erpressbar machen wenn
wir solche bilder auch zu lassen und es
ist ein dauerzustand also das mag dich
überraschen aber für diejenigen die sich
damit intensiver auseinandersetzen war
es klar dass es soweit kommen dünnsten
dauerzustand von vielen jahren und das
ist nicht nur in lesbos oder in moria
also das war ja im grunde genommen ein
durchgangslager was mittlerweile zum
verwahrungs lager geworden ist die
menschen sollten dort registriert werden
und dann eben auch weiter verteilt
werden aber die uneinigkeit europas
sorgt eben auch dann für diese bilder
für diese tragödien
wir nennen das dann flüchtlinge und das
löst bei den menschen viel aus das sind
menschen schicksale die dahinter stecken
das sind menschen die vor der taliban
geflohen sind
vor dem es vor dem assad-regime
und trotzdem kann ich als kind von
flüchtlingen keine garantie dafür
abgeben dass alle sozusagen die die
schutzbedürftigkeit ihr voraussetzen
aber das ist sozusagen auch ein
grundproblem mit dem wir uns hier
auseinandersetzen müssen es gibt keine
antwort auf europäischer ebene es gibt
keine menschenrechts geleitete
asylpolitik und das fällt uns jetzt
gerade vor die füße und wenn wir jetzt
auf europa warten dann könnt ihr lange
warten und deswegen glaube ich schon
dass deutschland jetzt auch gefragt das
zu sagen wir sind über 80 millionen
menschen
natürlich schaffen wir das wenn wir die
verteilen die kommunen die länder haben
sich bereits bereit erklärt und ich
finde es ganz wichtig eben auch ein
zeichen der humanität zu setzen
humanität auf der einen seite realität
auf der anhöhe hast wir nicht alle
aufnehmen können das ist schon hitler
das verstehe ich auch total und ich sage
ja auch sofort hilfe muss auf jeden fall
sein aber man muss auch mal gucken wo
liegt es begraben wo ist das problem da
muss auch natürlich wir kriegen dann
hinsetzen sagen welche regeln wurden
nicht gefolgt und wie konnte es so weit
kommen und die natürlich auch
dementsprechend dann auch erziehen
christine wie sie so dass wir die mwst
du diese situation war also
und das natürlich auch eine wahnsinnig
große tragödie und das ist einfach auch
schon über jahre so ist und eben nicht
wirklich angegriffen wird also angepackt
wird also da eine lösung zu finden sei
es jetzt national für deutschland oder
auch europa auf europaebene ich erlebt
es aber auch auf kommunaler ebene durch
diese organisation die seebrücke er zum
beispiel dieses bundesweit gibt die sich
dafür einsetzten wirklich flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen und sei es dann pro stadt
irgendwie pro kleinstadt auch vielleicht
nur mal 100 oder so oder zumindest
kinder oder eben unbetreut reisende und
da gibt es dann die stadt die sagt dazu
ja wir ermöglichen dass und dann gibt es
eine andere stadt gesagt nee das
schaffen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
also es herrscht eine große uneinigkeit
und das lässt mich dann auch so
verzweifelt weil ich dann wirklich denke
also dass den menschen also es ist
wirklich eigentlich unser oberstes gebot
eine hilfe zu leisten und wir schaffen
es irgendwie nicht und es fällt auch
irgendwie auf politischer ebene auch so
hinten runter ein bisschen also ist mein
eindruck also es wird auch viel zu viel
geredet schaut einfach mal hatten zeugen
zu lassen impulsen ich habe patrizia
besitzt ein bisschen anders aber ja ich
sehe ja und vor allem mehrere punkte
also zum einen muss man sagen wenn wir
jetzt in dieser situation und wir reden
nicht davon die flüchtlingsfrage
langfristig zu klären wenn wir jetzt in
dieser situation auf die eu wahl könnten
privaten können wir uns dumm und dämlich
warten die us friedensnobelpreisträger
hat hier völlig versagt wir müssen jetzt
diesen menschen helfen und zwar jetzt
und ich kann auch nicht verstehen dass
wir uns rausgehen und sagen es muss
eigentlich vom innenministerium herr
seehofer wenn da blockiert wir müssen
für solche fälle eine sonderregelung
finden wieso denn als beispiel wir und
müssen die menschen eher holen alle
kommunen alle städte die sich bereit
erklärt haben sollen besser jetzt und
besser von halben stunde die menschen
her holen die menschen schlafen hat auf
den straßen wir haben das nichts dass
ihr freude hatten auch noch verloren
dort ist gar nichts mehr wie man die
flüchtlingsfrage langfristig anhält ist
nun hoch komplexe frage die
wahrscheinlich hier die wir sitzen nicht
klären können wie wir die situation
jetzt lösen das kann man sehr schnell
klären
und trotzdem glaube ich dass es auch
noch mal wichtig ist klar zu machen dass
wir als deutschland glaube ich auch
schon eine verantwortung tragen
menschenwürdige
verhältnisse zu gewährleisten weltweit
das problem beginnt aber natürlich ganz
wo anders und ich würde sagen nicht nur
auf europa ebene sondern ganz global
also wie verhindern wir überhaupt dass
menschen sich auf den weg machen und wie
schaffen die legale wege
das mütter frauen und kinder überhaupt
die möglichkeit bekommen sich auf den
weg zu machen
wie schaffen wir aber auch legale
möglichkeiten für menschen die sagen ich
möchte auch über einen arbeitseinkommen
sozusagen mich ja verbessern integrieren
all das sind ja offene fragen all das
sind offene flanken und deswegen
produzieren wir ja diese bilder auf den
gefährlichen mittelmeer routen menschen
die wie gesagt die mes entkommen sind
und dann dort zu tode kommen also wir
hatten ja jetzt gerade auch diesen
gedenktag an alanco die beispielsweise
und trotzdem ist es wichtig und es ist
sozusagen auch makaber dass ich das
ansprechen muss als kind von
flüchtlingen meine eltern haben sich
auch eins auf den weg gemacht vor 50
jahren und ich bin sehr dankbar dafür
weil wir unterdrückt worden sind da wo
wir herkommen und das zeigt aber auch
die gemengelage dass es kompliziert ist
ob die politisch verfolgt bist ob du
sozusagen kriegsflüchtlingen bist ob es
akut ist und das sind natürlich alles
dinge die da mit hinein fließen und
trotzdem glaube ich dass die
integrationsfähigkeit in unserem land
begrenzt ist und dass wir es nicht
schaffen alle aufzunehmen und das kann
auch nicht unsere aufgabe sein sondern
wir müssen alle sozusagen mitnehmen und
wir müssen natürlich wenn wir wenn du
jetzt sagst dass die griechen dass wir
die erziehen müssen ich glaube die
würden sich dagegen verwehren endlich es
geht darum die griechen meinung wir ja
auch im stich gelassen dieses jahr auch
beschäftigt auch mit der türkei
beispielsweise um eine herausforderung
um den mittelmeerraum als krisengebiet
aber das war kultur was ich damit sagen
wollte ist mit erziehen jetzt einfach
dass ich meine es gab ein abkommen es
gab bestimmte regelungen es gab schon
mal geld es gab es gab es gab und
trotzdem wurden ganz viele regeln nicht
eingehalten was dazu jetzt geführt hat
dass diese situation natürlich
wahnsinnig eskaliert dass ich finde man
muss rein gehen und gucken wo das alles
passiert quasi nicht den den fisch
bringen sondern den beibringen wie man
angelt also das meine ich damit dass man
ein bisschen ein wir gefühl vielleicht
auch sogar damit erzeugen kann und nicht
unbedingt dagegen gehen und immer so und
so dass man die andere sache
was natürlich auch ganz viele stimmen
sind jetzt natürlich laut die dann auch
contra sagen ganz klar deutschland kann
ich immer herhalten deutschland kann ich
immer
geld geben wie seht ihr das können wir
das können wir das nicht christin also
ich glaube wir sind schon ein land das
sehr gut aufgestelltes finanziell und
auch viel abfedern kann
und mein eindruck ist ja auch was ich
auf in vielen interviews dann gelesen
habe
flüchtlinge die sich dann auch hier so
ein bisschen etabliert haben über eine
gewisse jahre vielleicht zwei drei vier
fünf jahre jetzt in den letzten zeit
hier geblieben sind eine ausbildung
vielleicht auch genossen haben die
wollen ja auch nicht alle in deutschland
bleiben also ich glaube diese angst dass
wir jetzt so überrannt werden von alten
oder so die wollen dann auch wieder
vielleicht in andere länder weiter oder
in ihr heimatland zurück sofern es jetzt
nicht sehr krisengeschüttelt nach wie
vor ist und so also von daher glaube ich
sind wir da gut aufgestellt in
deutschland wirklich humanitäre hilfe
also leisten zu können und auch einfach
aufnehmen zu können
bild von überzeugt jetzt auch gerne
fordern fordern würde ist bei den
politikern oder gibt es irgendwas wo du
sagst das fände ich gut wenn ihr das
machen dann also eine forderung stellen
also ich würde was ist wenn ich könnte
würde ich jetzt auch wie patricius auch
gesagt wirklich aktuell einfach sagen
jetzt muss gehandelt werden und die
kinder die ihr wirklich wenn man diese
bilder sieht also kinder einfach auf zu
nehmen jugendliche die eltern natürlich
irgendwie dazu sofern die überhaupt
gemeinsam auch geflohen sind und sich in
dem lager befinden einfach wirklich
konkret jetzt den aufruf holt die
hierher und das ist ja auch keine
flüchtlingskrise es ist eine verwaltungs
krise also ich finds auch ganz schwierig
zu sagen den flüchtlingen selber dafür
die schuld zu geben dass wir da keine
antwort für haben und wir werden
migration und völkerwanderung nicht
verhindern also die welt ist die
zentrale dafür müssen wir endlich mein
bewusstsein herstellen dass wir diese
rechte diese menschenrechte universell
einlösen müssen und es gibt akteure
weltweit aber wer sind unsere
bündnispartner da müssen wir uns ja auch
kritisch hinterfragen und wie entsteht
flucht also flucht entsteht natürlich
auch durch kriege durch völkermorde und
wie wird getötet mit waffen und da gibt
es ja auch geschäfte die dahinter
stecken also ich glaube wir müssen die
ganz großen fragen anfang zu stellen
verbunden eben damit zu sagen wie
schaffen wir lebensumstände die menschen
nicht dazu zwingen zu flüchten
die menschen wollen nicht flüchten die
tun das nicht
willich und wenn sie sich auf den weg
machen müssen wir natürlich auch gewisse
voraussetzungen auch zur verfügung
stellen oder sagst es ja auch selbst ist
ein sehr komplexes thema wo man sehr
auch in die tiefe gehen muss wo man auch
sehr weit blicken muss und dann frage
ich mich natürlich dann auch und viele
fahren sie das kann deutschland das kann
deutschland die welt retten nein nein
natürlich nicht sie auch nicht alleine
und ja auch nicht alleine da sind ja
jetzt wieder beim punkt regierte müssen
sie sagen doch deutschland kann das nach
dem ja ich bin leer tatsächlich recht
optimistische müssen ja auch gott sei
dank nicht die welt retten sondern wir
müssen jetzt die menschen von moria erst
mal retten und das schaffen wir davon
bin ich also um merkel zu zitieren das
schaffen wir
aber ich glaube ein punkt den düsen
angesprochen hat ist auch sehr sehr
wichtig ich glaube dass es uns sehr viel
besser gelingen muss menschen generell
zu integrieren
es kann ich möchte nie wieder solche
szenen sehen wie aus 2015 wo die
menschen campieren um sie zu
registrieren zu lassen und ein amt es
nicht bewältigen kann das zu sortieren
ich glaube das können wir uns als
deutschland einfach nicht erlauben
wir müssen angebote schaffen wir können
nicht wir können nicht zulassen dass
dass wir viele heime haben wo keiner
einen richtigen status hat und in
deutschland nicht arbeiten kann und dann
in die kriminalität abrutschen genau das
für die ganzen vorurteile weiter
befeuern die menschen haben wenn sie
sagen ja ich bin ich dass die alea komm
ich habe da angst mir macht das sorge
dann gehen wir damit noch futter wenn
wir dort versagen und ich finde da sind
sehr viele punkte
wo ist uns als deutschland nicht
gelungen ist gut dazustehen ich finde
das überhaupt nicht versorgt haben 2015
ich finde das war ja ein beispiel dafür
diese der jahr für das
menschenfreundliche deutschland damit
sind wir ja quasi in die geschichte
eingegangen und die tatsache dass wir
zum zweitbeliebtesten land der welt
gehören hat natürlich auch ganz viel
damit zu tun dass wir menschen
freundlich sind das wir
human sind aber dass wir auch
realistisch bleiben müssen und was ich
trotzdem vermisse ist das sozusagen auch
diese fragen zusammen mit der ganzen
gesellschaft auch beantwortet und
geklärt werden müssen dass das sozusagen
keine einzelfall entscheidungen sind
sondern dass wir eine
einwanderungspolitik machen müssen für
dieses land für deutschland nicht für
migranten nicht für flüchtlinge sondern
für uns alle
und da bin ich mir sicher dass jeder der
das auch vernünftig erklärt bekommt auch
mit geht bei denjenigen
die schutzbedürftig sind und trotzdem
sage ich dass die ängste die damit
verbunden sind und die im raum stehen
dass sie auch ernst genommen werden
müssen und die kommen ja auch von
unterschiedlichen seiten und wir können
dinge wie religiösen extremismus
terrorismus den können wir nicht
verhindern genauso wenig wie wir
rassismus verhindern können das heißt
haben sich menschen auf den weg hierher
gemacht und waren darunter auch menschen
die getötet haben ja aber waren darunter
auch menschen die getötet wurden aus
rassistischen motiven auch jahr und das
zeigt eben es gibt kein schwarz oder
weiß und wenn jemand vor allem
assad-regime fried dann ist er auf der
einen seite opfer er kann aber trotzdem
auch täter gewesen sein weil er islamist
war das heißt diese gemengelage mit
berücksichtigen da sind unsere
sicherheitsbehörden gefragt da ist
sozusagen auch im zusammenwirken aller
europäischen länder gefragt und da ist
vor allem auch eine europäische antwort
gefragt auch hier gilt wieder die
zivilgesellschaft ist schon viel weiter
als die institution und europa muss hier
antworten liefern
deswegen dürfte ja dann christine dürfte
das ich möchte auch als an die politik
fordern ich möchte deswegen wir haben
jetzt präsidentschaft in der baum hat
ruft frau merkel jetzt nicht ein
sondergipfel zusammen und konkret jetzt
für ihren nicht die große frage wie
gehen wir in zukunft was sind die
strategien konkret hilfe für ihr warum
passiert das nicht dass wir meine
forderung
[Musik]